hello everybody good morning uh we will
be uh
starting the webinar here shortly
um we'll just give give it a few more
minutes please
feel free to introduce yourselves on the
chat
box and as we go through the
session today
feel free also to post your questions
and we'll be happy to answer them as we
go through the session
welcome everybody um
just want to take this opportunity
before we start
we have anushka jane by tech graduate
also we have
robert weinberg welcome
sal sabil idris
welcome to the webinar
and we also have eric smith
uh welcome to the webinar feel free to
to introduce yourself on the chat box
uh cinalica can we go ahead and start
okay
good morning everyone do you hear me
alright loud and clear just want to make
sure everything is clear on my end we
hear you great
all right perfect thank you
um my name is jabs i'm one of the
marketing specialists uh here at pine
biotech working for the
omixlogic portal
or programs rather and i would like to
welcome to this overview session on the
summer 2022 omixlogic virtual training
programs
the session will give you additional
details about the program registration
levels of complexity and desired
outcomes you might be able to achieve
over the summer
now we have a range of options that you
can look into further and register by
the second by the end of the second week
of june
the programs will be offered virtually
around the topics
of coding
in r and python
infectious and chronic diseases as well
as a research project program that will
help you complete a research project
leveraging public domain data
big data infrastructure training and
support from our mentors
now because ultimately the methods are
best learned in the context of real case
studies prepared by our network of
mentors and collaborators that
illustrate how various bioinformatics
methods and omics data types are used in
current research in medicine
biotechnology agriculture and even
astrobiology
the projects are prepared by taking
publicly available data sets and using
them to explore and understand both the
research
research challenge and analysis path to
extract meaningful insights from complex
mixed data
the omics logic portal gives the
students options for analyzing a given
data set codependent
paths or code independent paths
now these data sets and associated
publications can be used in several ways
you can learn bioinformatics without any
coding at all
for that in each project we explain the
analysis pipelines on the user-friendly
tbio
platform for big data analysis
you can also learn the scripts behind
many of the steps learning to wrangle
clean visualize and analyze data in
popular languages like r and python
in order to create your own analysis
finally you can hear about the projects
and their research applications in our
mentor guided programs where experts
share the experience and support
research projects developed by you
let's start by signing up to learn
omics logitech portal
and this educational portal will help
you get started on your bioinformatics
journey
we will be chat i will be posting the
link on the chat box
and we will give you a few minutes to
to visit the omixlogic portal and be
able to sign up if you still have not
created your profile
i would like to encourage everyone for
those who have not created their profile
this will be a
great time for you to be able to get
started
and if you have any questions or issues
in signing up
please feel free to reach out and
one of our team will be able to
assist you
so the link is learn.mixlogic.com
and let me know if you have trouble uh
looking for
the page where you need to sign up it's
at the top right of the page
so for those who have signed up on the
portal if you can please type yes in the
chat box
okay perfect we have a couple people who
already have signed up
anybody having trouble signing up on the
omixlogic portal right now
yes the link is learn.omicslogic.com
i'm posting that link right there
okay thank you robert
all right
okay so i'm going to move on
so when you create your profile you
would like we would like to encourage
you to update your profile in order to
track activity
and issue achievement badges and
certifications
now a complete profile includes a
profile picture
you can use your avatar or a university
logo if you don't want to use your
personal picture
you may also connect a
social media account either facebook
linkedin instagram or twitter account
and last but not least is your biography
in which if you can please uh provide a
short
uh or brief bio about yourself including
your research interests
so this is what you will see when when
you have completed your
i mean when you sign up for the portal
this is where you will see your activity
a couple of tabs that i want to
to introduce is the activity tab the
courses tab programs and certificates
tab so as you um
complete or enroll courses this is where
you will actually see all the activities
and we will uh
we'll get through that on the next
slides
so after successfully completion of a
program you will be awarded with a
certificate
and you'll be able to view or access
your certifications through your profile
if you see earlier on the previous slide
there is a certificate tab that's where
you can access all the
completed certifications and you'll be
able to download it from there as well
after you register you will be
redirected to the courses tab and here
you can search for any course title
and use the tags to find series of
resources around a topic or choose one
of the collections down below
which is highlighted in red
and in this video we will look at the
getting started
collection
i also like to add that these getting
started courses are free and for anyone
who want to get into the bioinformatics
and you're welcome to share with your
network as well to take these courses
under the programs tab of your profile
is where you find the assigned programs
of your choice now each program has a
schedule
sequence of events and every event has
recorded sessions and assignments
designed around that topic and each
activity you complete will get points
which are for completing the course
which is 500 points running a pipeline
100 points
as soon as you update your profile you
also get another 100 points and for any
group activity that you complete is
about 10 points and you will see that
under the activity tab
with all the logs or the every mileage
that you have completed
now in this program you will also be
taken through project examples on the
omixlogic portal
which will help you understand the
practical applications of various omex
data analysis and learn how it will be
applied
to answer research questions in hand and
finally designing your own
bioinformatics research project indeed
during this meeting you will be able to
learn about the upcoming training
programs offered by the national
association of idea principal
investigators or nepi on bioinformatics
we will focus on three programs
bioinformatics for infectious diseases
genomics and transcriptomic data
analysis to study viral and bacterial
pathogens as well as host
immune responses
transcriptomic data analysis for chronic
diseases such as cancer metabolic and
many others
bioinformatics using r and python
getting started with sequence and
structured data analysis in r or python
in addition we will be sharing more
information about the omics logic
research fellowship a program designed
to help young investigators complete a
full bioinformatics project over the
summer
and presented during our virtual summer
research symposium
to achieve this goal we use a
combination of online sessions
self-guided study materials
and practical assignments for an
immersive experience that has proven to
be effective in our well-known and
respected omixlogic programs
now to talk in detail about the upcoming
summer programs i would like to invite
dr raghavendran
dr raghavendran is an accomplished
computational biologist with experience
in large-scale analysis of multi-omits
data and data science methods in
precision oncology
and protein dna structural
bioinformatics
i will pass on the stage to you dr roger
benjamin
thank you very much jobs let me find
ways to share my screen and confirm that
i am audible to all of you
can you stop sharing your screen jacks
sure sure
bear with me
okay
there you go
thank you very much and uh please
confirm that you can see me screaming
yes doctor
you can see your screen and your
perspective thank you very much
okay so i thank once again caps and i am
raghavendran
bioinformatics mentor with fine biotech
and i welcome you all to this overview
session on the summer 22 homicide
training programs so this part of this
session will give you more detail and
additional details about the program
design about the curriculum and about
resources so uh as you know this summer
we have a range of programs that you can
look into further and register
so that you can learn a little bit more
about bioinformatics and how it is
applied to various different uh
topics related to biology and
bioinformatics
so this this program will generally be
offered virtually around the topics of
infectious diseases uh it also includes
coding in r and in python it also
includes
bioinformatics analysis of gene
expression data in transcriptomics
and in general introduction to big data
bioinformatics so
this
program will actually help you to
complete a research at the end of this
we also have a research fellowship
program and dr mohit will talk more
about this research fellowship program
so this research fellowship program is
is specifically designed to help you
complete a project leveraging public
domain data from using big data
infrastructure and
and exploiting training and support from
all of us from our team and our mentors
so let's go uh to little bit more detail
about these programs
one by one and understand what they
offer to students and faculties
so
we start with introduction to
bioinformatics where we actually
can you hear me
can you mute yes thank you very much yes
sir you can proceed further
sharon can you put your query in the
chat means we answer your query towards
the end of the session thank you so much
over to you sir
yes thank you very much
please
yeah
please put your queries and enter your
queries in the chat i'm following chat
as i'm
chatting with you so uh
so let me
share again
so the introduction to bioinformatics
program is designed to introduce you to
the world of big data biology and
data science tools
so it starts with the basics of next
generation sequencing and it starts with
what are the different omics data types
that you will be learning and what are
the different omics data types that are
used
generally to understand the biology and
different biology of the system from
molecular level it also extends to what
are the uh analysis methods and options
that we have to um
use for or to uh
to employ on different omics data types
so that we can extract the maximum
information from these data types okay
somebody says that my uh voice is so
feeble let me uh sound up thank you very
much
so in the end by the end of this big
data informatics program you'll also get
an introduction to how to use
how to apply advanced statistical
methods like machine learning and deep
learning to
the structured data that we generate
from this next generation sequencing
data so in the end you will achieve all
of your achievements will be summarized
in certificates that you can share with
your
peers
so
yeah
this you went through we have several
extensive training materials
prepared for you like associated courses
lessons from omixlogic platform
asynchronous videos live hands-on demo
sessions and we also have prepared
curated example projects
and
which takes a publication and the data
associated with the publication
to um
[Music]
to an analysis method of its own and and
walks you through the whole process of
from the dataset through
this uh through specifically designed
analysis methods for the data set and
biological interpretation and conclusion
and comparison with the original
findings and we also have um
in the research fellowship program that
you will you will hear today so we
promote project-based uh learning and
interactive sessions for exploring uh
bioinformatics as uh as a as an option
so we also have uh
several uh lessons which are coding
lessons that that have that is
structured in an interactive fashion so
that you can explore coding for
bioinformatics
so the analysis methods that we have
discussed or that we have in uh that we
have in hand for different omics data
are are usually applied or employed in
two approaches so one of the approaches
for code independent uh approach is is
for those who who does not want to
venture into the world of coding and who
is not very comfortable in coding
so these methods these code
independent
infrastructure methods will include
hands-on exercises in our big data
bioinfo platform like tbio info platform
and this provides a simple and intuitive
user interface for processing analysing
analyzing
and
digital data
and different structural
structure data also so so we can employ
all different kinds of analysis methods
here you will get a five terabyte
storage so that you can store your data
that usually is huge when you involve
big data bioinformatics and you will get
support from us and you will also get um
and get all the necessary associated
resources and lessons and
videos so that you can set up your
analysis pipeline independently and uh
and vary the methods in the analysis
pipeline to suit your data so this
analysis pipelines include both the
analysis of next generation sequencing
data to arrive at a structured table to
structure data or a structural list of
variants
and then from there it will also uh it
also includes a downstream analysis of
whatever you have generated the
structured data that you have generated
so that the downstream analysis applies
various statistical methods machine
learning methods so that you can infer
and explore the meaningful relationships
that is buried deep within your data
so
here is an example of the code
independent pipeline that i was talking
about and this pipeline builder
interface in the in the tbio info
platform is color coded um
so that you can establish a connection
between
a logical connection between how your
analysis methods are
progressing and the data input is an
input file and the analysis can be
chosen based on the type of research and
the type of question that you are going
to ask we usually have three basic
colors that separates the analysis
methods blue is for preprocessing red is
for mapping and green is for
quantification and you can explore
oranges for downstream analysis the
interactive output we we also have
option for interactive output which
allows for easy visualization of the
data outputs and there are several demo
pipelines which will um which will give
you an experience of setting up an
original pipeline and downloading the
output associated output
to get a feel for how to set up big data
bioinfo
informatics pipeline for next generation
sequencing data and for downstream
analysis and what are the different kind
of outputs that you will get and how you
can make sense of this output in the
connotation with the biological
relevance or phenotypical
association of the samples
so this is part of the interactive
output
so for those who want to
expand your skill sets to coding and
venture into the into learning coding
along with their analysis we have
lessons that involve coding and these
lessons are divided into um into several
steps so the first one of first step is
always to understand the context or the
aim of the analysis and it follows it is
followed with the logic behind the
analysis that we are performing and then
we have a learn the code section
yeah
learn the code section but each and
every parts of this code are
explained to you uh in a in
in a small piece by piece manner and
finally you'll have practice the course
section where you can practice whatever
you have learned and then in the end you
will have option to download or you'll
have option to access the full code
document in a jupyter notebook or a
google call up notebook format so that
you can independently modify the code to
suit your analysis or data requirements
so each session is actually planned uh
for for an hour-long
video and
you will have
more associated resources that you will
have to go through and i think our
sonalika will actually talk more about
how much you should spend for each and
each and every one of these sessions so
that you can
gain or get maximum information from
these sessions or research from the
sessions
so yeah
so
for our next program we have biomedical
data analysis using r and python so the
introduction to bioinformatics section
will introduce you to the different
analysis methods but if you want to
delve deep into the into the world of
data analysis and data science of bio
omics data or big or mixed data then you
have to choose an option like this so in
this
program for example the focus is on
learning data science and not
programming so programming we use as a
tool to learn data science the more
focus and emphasis is on understanding
the logic behind the methods and
tweaking certain part of the programming
or of the code blocks so that it suits
your
data or your analysis methods so
yeah
so why do we choose only python and r so
we know that python and r are the major
resources that is used for
bioinformatics data analysis and i don't
want to create any uh war between
people who like python and people who
like are so we are on the fence or we
are we are of uh of uh of an opinion
that it is not a good idea as a
bioinformatics enthusiast or of a data
science synthesis to pigeonhole yourself
into one of these methods both have
their advantage and both have their
shortcomings
so you should learn enough of enough
concepts from both the tools as much as
you can so that you can apply either one
of them depending upon the type of data
depending upon the type of analysis that
you use and that is what we also promote
for most of the lessons that you have we
have all these analysis methods divided
into three parts the first part as i
actually um
actually mentioned earlier it's code
independent block where you can get the
experience of performing these analysis
using the big data bioinfo platform and
the second portion is running the same
analysis in an environment like r and
the third one is using environment like
python so you will have um complementary
information from all these three
different resources
so we first start with the basics of
getting started with r and python where
we start uh absolutely from the basic
like uh how to load the data into rs
environment or how to load a file into
python's environment which is
which is absolutely the most necessary
skill that you want to have if you want
to use r and python for bioinformatics
data analysis and then we up the up the
ante with trying to analyze or trying to
read dna sequences and how to compare
dna sequences in r and python and how to
uh
how to take your first steps into
bioinformatics data analysis so all of
the data that is discussed and all of
the data that you are going to load are
from from either of the omics data
specifically prepared and specially
prepared for you to run all these
analysis in your uh
in the interactive platform that you
will learn are in your our studio that
you have locally installed our python
environment that you have locally
installed in your um in your computer
and we
and then to increase
the applications of r and python into
the world of data science we have
several different data processing and
visualization and advanced visualization
methods that you will get hands on to
and how different visualization is also
going to help you learn about the
patterns that you can generally observe
from the data it's just not
you run this code boom you get a scatter
plot if you run this code you get a
histogram but more emphasis is on what
are you going to learn from histogram
and why is histogram a better option
when compared to scatter plot so more of
these kind of discussion is what we will
be having
this one so to to start uh from the from
the from absolute basic you always have
to start from somewhere so we we have to
give you
a detailed introduction in in the first
lesson or introduction into the
introduction to bioinformatics analysis
in r about some of the concepts that you
will mostly use or you will use
frequently in your data analysis like um
uh
what are the different objects like data
frame under array and matrix that you
will be using for your omics data
analysis what are the different basic
functions like how to find the dimension
of the array how to find the size of
some of the elements and how to find
that uh how to
index or take specific portions from the
data file or how to restructure data
frame basic on your based on your
requirements so all of these would be
covered extensively up at the start and
then as you progress uh in
in the program so these will be uh
used repetitively
so that you can get a feeling for how
these are used in the or mixed data
analysis so you can you can you can say
that we uh in in python or in our world
we actually quickly um
introduce you
uh
after your data exploration and data
loading and transforming you we quickly
introduce you to advanced statistical
methods like machine learning and uh
with supervisor unsupervised machine
learning and comparing different
supervised classification algorithm and
etcetera so this is this is in bio ml
cores in python which
and also available in r which compares a
different machine learning methods for
the same or similar data so that you can
clearly get a get an understanding of
how
same or similar uh analysis methods
interpret the pattern that is uh
that you can find or that is that is
available in the data that is present in
the data
so always you start with load and
transform and start exploring the data
and then before uh going into further
analysis methods so all of these methods
will actually take the structured data
that i was talking to you about so this
this is a table output tabular output
that you can generally
get access to from publicly available
dataset or if you have next generation
sequencing data you can get to the
structured data from um
from running one of those pipelines that
we have discussed before and you will
also see one more example of that
so the practical coding assignments in
uh in our learn
in the portal on portal is designed in
such a way that it will help you to
understand that different elements of
code are
from coding python for example this is
an example of interactive console that
we are going to offer you for both
python and our environment where you
will have your code
where you you'll have the code that you
can write on the console and then the
console will uh um and the right portion
of the console will uh will be the will
be where it is being executed and and
then
interactive output is going to be
printed out and you will also have if
you have a codes to prepare or if you
have codes to print out plots and the
plots will also appear below so this is
embedded into each and every one of
these coding lessons so that whatever
you have achieved in learning the code
section you can apply it in into this
practice the code area
so and and we also gave you we also have
um some more test your ability to fill
up the codes where we
modify some of the
some of the
coding
coding
codes so that too uh so that you can
complete those syntaxes and we
deliberately leave out some parts of the
code so that you can
you can
access yourself or you can try to
complete those course and
learn from these learn the code
separation area so once you are through
with the practice
section where you have completed these
codes successfully and these practice
sections are designed in such a way to
increase the level of difficulties and
once you are through you will be given
either
an option to perform an assignment or
complete an assignment uh or
you'll be given access to google
collaboratory notebook or jupyter kind
of jupyter notebook kind of
link where you can get all the codes
that are discussed in the lesson and
little bit more uh more other options
also so you can get a feeling for
running the code um either either one by
one or in unison from start to and and
you also since you have the access you
also have the freedom to play with the
code to change the analysis methods to
compare one method with the other one
and etc
so
as i as i mentioned at the start we
don't focus on making you learn
programming
um
we don't focus on making you learn
programming but we let you understand
the data science aspect of the
programming so um
how different strategies of these
analysis work together and how how by
employing different data processing
methods will help you define the
hypothesis will help you refine the
hypothesis and will help you prepare the
data for meaningful applications most of
the time in in the data science
application method most of the time
spent in this this part in this portion
and this portion the data analysis and
summary of statistics will take only uh
very um
will take limited amount of your time
unlimited amount of your coding uh areas
so go back i think yeah so most of the
time you're going to spend in processing
cleaning and pre-processing the input
data such that it fits the
analysis requirements of uh it fits the
statistical requirements of different
analysis methods and data mining and
visualization and exploratory analysis
perform very important part key portion
in refining your hypothesis you look for
pattern if that pattern is is present
then you refine your hypothesis or if if
some of the initial early exploratory
visualization provides you with a
different uh um
different idea or a different view so
you expand on that you go in that
direction that's the power of data
science we don't start with the fixed
hypothesis we explore the data for
available hypothesis and then we keep
refining the hypothesis so that our data
can explore the
explore the current
relationships in in the in the features
or in the genes certain different uh
different aspects of different uh
portions of the data to reject or accept
uh or to
evaluate the hypothesis so i have a
question where um before going next when
using code written by someone else there
are concerns about copyright issues and
whether it is necessary to get coder's
permission to copyright
so if the if you are getting the code or
if you are downloading the code from the
coders computer without their
without their knowledge then of course
you have to get permission but there are
codes which are
left for you to explore in the freely
available resources like github or in
google collaboratory so
in these portions you can just mention
modified from this code so that you are
being a good person and then
acknowledging from where the code source
is being taken from and most of the
publication nowadays require you or
require the authors to give link to
their code so that people can reproduce
their selves so once they give
permission or once they upload the code
in in downloadable
public resources and repositories like
google collaboratory or sorry google
collabs and in
and then github then it is free for you
to take uh provided that you acknowledge
them accordingly so we whenever you want
to take codes written by somebody please
acknowledge them this is a code that
that is taken from this link and it is
modified to suit this specific uh
concern this specific analysis
okay
so so the difference between uh
for example choosing a specific or mixed
data analysis track and choosing okay i
went back again sorry choosing specific
comics data analysis track and program
and choosing
data science programming data science
track is that
in the data science track you will get
uh you will you will have experience in
dealing with dealing with the structured
data that is generated from variety of
different omics data analysis you can
get either transcriptomics data you can
get a list of variants in the genomics
data and you can get abundance
information abundance table from the
metagenomic
metagenomics
which one of these data structure data
that you can get your hands on requires
different
concoction or different
combinations of programming methods and
so that
you can
explore the variety of patterns that is
that is associated in the data that is
buried deep in the data so this can be
as simple as
the analysis can be as simple as
performing a teachers in excel or as
complex as performing uh hierarchical
clustering or
unsupervised clustering and then
followed by
supervised classification for different
of the different one of these clusters
so it can go from very simple methods to
even complex and complicated methods
so the next program we have in our hand
is
is focused on transcriptomics data
analysis for chronic diseases and uh
this in this program we will discuss
various aspects of uh transcriptomic
data analysis which is also called as
rna-seq data analysis and how
this specific field of bioinformatics
has evolved and continued to evolve to
help us understand the disease biology
or systems biology from the disease this
is biology from the systems aspect
biology aspect so the technique and and
the analysis methods and
and the
bioinformatics analysis for
understanding the patterns within the
data and the comparative analysis of
this data has evolved and has been
defined over the years now it is at a
point where
all of these data analysis can be run
without or with minimal user inter
intervention
and it is now regularly used by many
scientists and
and has been performed um
used for in-depth analysis of gene
expression data and isoform expression
data to study the transcriptomic
landscape of the diseased state or
altered state etc so um
so we know that the genomics data has
provided genomics and
transcriptomic data has provided new
ways and new options and new dimensions
to link targets to disease and how to
validate these targets the result of
this
genomics data revolution is is the
potential for a new era of drug
discovery and transcriptomics is at the
right
right
at the pedestal for those drug discovery
um discovery of the drugs that control
disease through
regulating gene expression for example
or by mimicking mimicking the mechanisms
by which our body exits control over a
range of normal and disease functions so
the
the underlying data that is required for
performing a transcriptomic data
analysis as you would have guessed
comes from next generation sequencing
and let's talk about ngs and what it
represents in transcriptomics data
compared to the other techniques and
also get a brief introduction to how
traditionally
mrna abundance or express gene gene
expression abundance has been measured
quickly so uh
so as a method of measuring rna
translation transcriptomics
studies actually help us to detect mrna
expression inside the cell and this mrna
expression will act as an accurate
alternative to
alternative or accurate proxy to the
conditions of the cell that it
represents so this conditions and this
phenotypic this
transcriptomics landscape or expression
landscape
can can help us to help us understand um
for example
the disease biology or the development
of resistance for a particular treatment
or generally the difference in in the
molecular pathways and difference in the
biological function that that one set of
tissues uh
establish or one set of tissues um
excerpt over i mean compared to the
other set of tissues so at the forefront
or at the basic level we have to measure
the mrna
level or the amount of mrna present in
the cells
present in the tissues so how do we do
that traditionally this has been done
using microarray technologies more about
this and comparing and contrasting
microarrays and ngs are detailed in this
program but
with each and every iterations
or reach development in technology uh
involved in measuring the
mrna abundance we
get more and more data on more and more
information
regarding
uh regarding the
cell regarding the phenotype of disease
biology of the cell so i in the end what
we would like to have is something like
uh something like this where the genes
and the isoforms of the genes will
actually represent the difference in the
type of samples or difference in the
phenotype of the samples that it that it
is taken from so
depending upon your analysis methods
depending upon your type of question you
can either go for traditionally
understanding or analyzing the gene
expression landscape or you can go for
isoform expression landscape where you
will get your hands on or where you will
get information about the
alternative splice forms of the genes
that you are analyzing
so this yeah as we said this yeah this
this will uh extending your analysis
method to include isoforms will actually
help you uh understand or help you um
identify some unannotated
exons or novel transcripts which have
not been characterized before so that
can be very crucial in understanding the
disease biology
so these patterns and gene expression
patterns and transcriptomic landscape
can be uh can help you identify or help
you help you understand the biological
markers or bio markers
for which is
always used for um
which is uh used to uh
used in the clinical data diagnostics
and clinical therapy selection selection
of different therapies and improvement
of clinical diagnosis so uh
more and more of these data and more and
more new discoveries based on these
expression patterns and isothermic
expression patterns will help us
understand these complex diseases at the
subcellular level also from the uh
target identification for the new or
repurposing of existing drugs or novel
drug design
so
these this is transcriptomics program
and this program includes six or seven
interactive session we will cover all
these topics within this interactive
session in addition to this you will get
a practical hands-on where um
you will get yeah you will understand
the logic behind setting up this
transcriptomics data analysis which we
will discuss in detail i will go rush a
little bit yeah i will rush a little bit
quickly here and
in the end of this analysis you will get
a list of uh output files which you can
either explore them interactive
or download them to uh use it for your
report or use it in your analysis
using your analysis so in addition to
identifying differentially expressed
genes which is a which is a which is
which is the aim of performing
transcriptomic data analysis you can
also understand how different ah
different pathways are enriched or
suppressed
because of the
genes that are differentially expressed
in the conditions that we are
analyzing or
comparing so yeah the basic this this we
will this i will skip and the outputs
are
you will get a myriad of variety of
outputs which will include tables which
will include the plots and which will
include
which will also include visual uh output
interactive visual output so all of this
will help you understand the biological
phenomena or clinical communication of
the disease
so
as i mentioned this as i mentioned
this structured data can be used for
further data science based uh analysis
and yeah this we already discussed so we
we will skip so you also get an
introduction to single cell
transcriptomics which is uh
you also get an introduction to singles
and transcriptomics which uh which can
help us understand uh all the messenger
rnas that are present in single cell
resolution so it is not like bulk cell
profiling which we have been discussing
so far where the sequence libraries are
created for uh for an average mrna
expression quantification for a
different uh for a tissue here you'll
get the tissue composition at the single
cell resolution let's quickly skip
through a couple of these parts we have
one more program to cover so this
actually tells the power of single cell
analysis
pipeline analysis where you can for
example here where you can get
different
cell types that populate a tissue so
that you can understand the
heterogeneity behind the tissue that you
are analyzing in a much more uh clear
fashion so this level of resolution you
will not obtain or you will not get from
bulk cell rna analysis
a bulcell rna analysis and single cell
rna analysis
complements the balsa rna
understanding of the disease biology in
a very uh upcoming and a novel fashion
so um
the next program that we are going to
discuss is for multi-omics for
infectious diseases so here we will
speak about in this program we will
discuss about the emergence and
development of infectious disease
research area and how bioinformatics is
contributing uh contributing uh to this
infectious disease research so we will
actually use again the next generation
sequencing data and how they can be used
and how they can
they can be employed to characterize and
understand the infectious diseases the
pathogens from
a data perspective
so yeah
so in this program we will show you
examples of uh how to perform or we will
provide you training on how to perform
sequence variation analysis and
alignment analysis and how to perform
phylogenetic analysis so that you can
understand for example uh
where you were where you were sars
variant or
related to our lie in the lineage of
variance of concern or villages of least
concern
and we will also extend this analysis to
understand the functionality and the 3d
structure of the protein and how a
protein structure can be related
to ah to the to its function and why it
is important in the connotation of um
pathogen in
infection infectious diseases and
pathogens and tree into the post so in
the end you will also get
get the host side of comics data
analysis we can record what the host how
the hosts respond to different
pathogen
pathogenic infection and from from
understanding the
transcriptomic landscape of those
response we can get an idea of what are
the different ways the hosts or we as a
host are trying
uh to attack the viral outbreak and
virus output
uh with will the multi-omics data it
teaches to make hierarchical clustering
based on dna sequence analysis for a
particular genome using yes you can
perform uh clustering using
particular gene or a set of genes
using coding yes that that is included
in in this as well uh in this part as
well so
[Music]
and yeah okay perfect let me
can you can somebody mute your screen
mute mute yourself i think we have some
disturbances coming up
so okay okay thank you
so we we yeah so i wanted to talk to you
a little bit more about infectious
diseases how how it is different from
non-infectious diseases and why we are
to study uh the differences between
infectious diseases i will not go over
much detail but we say that infections
are caused by agents that we call as
pathogens and these are usually
virus viroids fungi parasites and
bacteria and non-infectious diseases are
caused by
caused by nutrition deficiency or caused
by chronic development of a different
chronic response to different factors
like environment lifestyle and it can
also come from genetic inheritance and
uh etc etc so um
we i want to give you uh yeah um a
special overview of how
how
omics data is actually helping in
understanding the infectious diseases
case so at the same time when we are
developing lot of new techniques to
study these pathogens under microscope
we also have started developing
sequencing technologies so these two
technologies especially in infectious
disease biology complement each other so
um so
the data that we get and the biology
that we study is rich and it has
completely transformed our understanding
of infectious diseases i don't have to
give lot of examples because we are
currently in a pandemic
era and ebola the epidemic that we
encountered in
2014 to 16
excuse me is is one of the first
epidemic to be tracked in real time
using next generation sequencing data so
for for understanding multi-omics
integration in um
in infectious disease biology we don't
have to go far but we can easily take
the ebola pandemic as a case study to
understand how different strains of
ebola are characterized and how
different outbreaks of ebola are
actually um contained
by analyzing the next generation
sequencing data and how we are repeating
the same for
sar score with data all of your variance
of concern and variance of least concern
and double mutant triple mutant of these
variations of these delta and omicron
variants are actually
employing next generation sequencing
data for their characterization so
so as a result as we know that the omics
data is
is now regularly used to study viral
genomes it's used to study dna
variations it's used to study
pathogenic gene expression or host sorry
not pathogenic explain post gene
expression data and host protein
abundance and the composition of
different properties of
like microbial community in the meta
genomic center so all of these different
types of data that we have
need to be need to be
effectively analyzed and need to be
mined for different patterns to
understand how hosts respond to the
pathogenic
invasion and how generally pathogen
employs different parts of host protein
machinery to
for its own purpose
so in the end of all these you will you
will be uh you will understand and you
will come develop
a deep understanding in the processing
and analysis methods that are used to
integrate genomic transcriptomic and
meta genomic data so that you can
you can mine
what's in there
we don't have crispr also but if you can
find crisper data that will complement
omix data
nothing stops you from using that sugar
so yeah
we can we give you methods to study
relationship based on uh for example low
positive for example a
local and multiple sequence comparison
using uh using phylogenetic analysis and
phylogenetic analysis will give you a uh
give you a new world into the
reconstruction of evolutionary
patterns for for example for viruses and
for for different pathogens we also give
you um
different for example
chemical and structural variations that
is observed in the sequence amino acid
sequence that are mapped onto the
protein
from for example in the surface protein
of sars on the surface protein of ebola
are in the genes of mycobacterium
tuberculosis and etc and we also give
you ways to understand uh the immunology
immune response of the host by studying
their transcriptomics data uh
transcriptomics landscape for a
pathogenic
invasion so with that i can take some
questions that you are
that you are busy with or you are
typing with um
and then if you have no further
questions i will pass the stage to dr
mohit who is going to talk to you about
uh research fellowship
thank you raghav i think there are a few
questions
yeah
in the chat so once you can cover those
i'll i'll share my screen sure
so uh
vishnu writes i wanted to find out how
disrupting a specific gene impacts other
genes and also in protein expression in
its network do you think bioinformatics
using r and python is a right fit for
this goal you can use yeah yes i mean
wherever you can find the data to
analyze and big data to analyze you can
use r and python so aren't python
just really tool to analyze a
bioinformatics data i think you should
focus more about what is the specific
question and what is the logic behind
those analysis so if this analysis
involves you to run this
run couple of uh
analysis methods by submitting this to
these two online servers so be it you
run it but the end result should be
should be you should understand the
disease biology as you mentioned to
understand how specific gene impacts
other genes you can for example i will
give you a hint you should look for hub
genes you should look for how people
identify hub genes from protein
co expression network gene coexpression
network that will give you a hint on how
to perform this analysis and what to
disrupt in the gene expression landscape
or gene expression patterns and
what else do we have at part maybe
cancer genomic force will be good for
you i think i am interested in neuro
oncology and metabolomic research which
program would be helpful for me um
okay
yeah i mean since you have oncology you
can use cancer and most of the cancer
genomics we study use transcriptomics
data analysis so i would point you to uh
transcriptomics data analysis
program so that is uh with that you can
probably answer your uh question trying
to understand metabolomic research and
neuro ontology area
so uh gizelle actually writes i am
interested in species genetic structure
phylogeny and chemical composition based
on uh structure which program will fill
the multi omics program or multi omics
data analysis program for infectious
gcses would perfectly fit your needs
giselle so that includes these analysis
methods where we are comparing genetic
genome sequences where we are performing
palo genetic tree analysis where we are
also going to understand how
mutations in the
in the genome gene of specific region
will affect the will will or could
affect the protein function
so that is that will fit your needs and
van dijk will yeah i i analyze i
actually answered the question on
hierarchical clustering and we have
we have thank you thank you i think with
that
i can pass this stage to dr mohit who's
been patiently waiting over to you
thank you
raka
uh so can you confirm if my screen is
visible
uh yesterday
all right thank you hello everyone it's
it's really pleasure to meet you all
so today we are meeting as an
orientation session for the
2022 lbi environment
and nappy virtual summer programs so in
this summer programs as we've been
discussing about different topics and
different curriculums i think a great
question would be like what is the right
fit and
how they are categorized
so a little bit about that so the
introduction to bioinformatics program
that we discussed uh
first is a beginner level program that
has
sessions designed to take you through uh
big data and then take you through the
ole mix technologies you'll learn about
genomics you'll learn about
transcriptomics and you'll have access
to a lot of asynchronous material which
will make this a lot easier for you to
learn at your own pace at your own time
and at your own convenience
we will have live sessions uh for
queries q and a's and we will also go
through some specific case studies that
will help you understand about specific
research
may that be genomical research that how
it can be applied so that's one of the
key advantages of mixed logic training
is just not based on you know um
the
technology itself but also the case
studies and how
it's applied for research and now um
again uh the first program that i
discussed and the second program which
will be on uh data analysis uh
biomedical data analysis using rn python
is a again a beginner level and an also
an intermediate level uh training
program so for this uh r and python
i mean we need to understand that where
this is applied and especially in the
context of research so you'll see a lot
of publications published directly
recent publications in nature cell and
science and all the good journals are
out there
high impact journals they use a lot of
visualization which are really
compelling to look at and also at the
same time one can understand that what
this experiment is all about and how uh
how can you
actually visualize a huge amount of
information into a small piece of you
know i would say art so this is where r
and python are really really massively
used and there is a lot of application
hence in bioinformatics and biological
research so it's a great program for
beginner level who have not experienced
this and have not been using this for
their own publications reports and all
of that
is a is a good fit now um the
transcriptomics for chronic diseases i
mean as dragon said transcriptomics uh
is a very important topic in today's
modern uh era in biomedical research so
it is uh the transcriptomics research is
again a beginner and an also an
intermediate level uh training program
uh which because i all of these training
programs have a
very basic introduction
that allows anyone from any background
to actually learn about the topic but
obviously basic biology molecular
biology is something that we expect you
to know a little bit and uh then uh one
of the biggest uh you know expectations
that we will have if you're a beginner
level is to complete the asynchronous
coursework because they are they are not
just like any other courses they are
more like practical tutorials that will
help you like to go through a case study
that will help you to understand that
how this is connected with the tv info
server and how can all of this can be
conceptualized into uh you know
research into a research project and
that is what i wanted to discuss today
in this session now the last
level
which is i would say
an advance level because you will have
to work on a project and
i think many of you who are thinking
about the project has already some ideas
in their mind um maybe it's related to
the
research that is ongoing or some of the
new technologies that you're hearing
about or it could be about the lab that
you're working in and you have some
specific interests and specific ideas
that you wanted to explore so it's it's
an amazing amazing program this research
fellowship i would say because
it's like an experience that takes you
to use the high grade training research
tools and then you get to do the
hands-on analysis and then work on work
and apply multi-omics data or any sort
of data
that is publicly available to these
different research fields so it does not
stop you to work on a very specific
research field you can have any of the
research fields that that are out there
that uses biological data and generate a
research idea and work on that idea but
obviously there is a requirement for you
to know how to use the t-bind for
platform you don't know how to use rn
python maybe for visualization you don't
know also how do you come up with you
know research um question that is one of
the biggest biggest
roadblocks to work on a research
research project
so i mean this entire research uh
ominous logical research training is uh
very well structured and uh i would say
this is very well structured because
we have been able to do this in a very
short period of time considering people
will end up doing phds and they end up
doing working for a very long time to
get some of the outcomes that we are
getting in a very quick time and that is
all because of the platform that is all
because of the sim
because we are trying to simplify all of
this uh because this is also a complex
way of you know train of uh applying um
uh and understanding how big data how
this
huge huge amount of information can be
summarized and make meaningful
information insights that really helps
in translational research so big deal
yeah
so that's why we are what we are doing
is that we have this basic coursework
then we have these tools then we have
the platform then we have this research
specialization areas and we talked about
special
case studies that anyone can go through
and learn about the specific kind of
research and then uh the next the last
step is to start working on your own
idea generate results and interpretation
work with a mentor work with us work
with a team of um
collaborators or team of uh team of
experts and collaborators across the
world so this is what the research
fellowship training program is all about
and obviously it guarantees some of the
outcomes and that we have been able to
get through this sort of training that
is that people are being able to
highlight showcase and also get results
to
to a level that can be
a preprint that can be a poster
presentation that can be a full uh
full publication
um more about it to understand that how
do we integrate all of this there is a
there's a
there are collaborators from our partner
universities they are omis logic
research fellows who are already in this
community so we have a community of over
15 000 people who are researchers for
students for faculty who are from
company
and uh it's really good to have like a
public profile on omix logic learn
because what we are also doing is that
connecting research projects with
interests in research companies and
companies who are startup companies who
are in pharma so we also have a linkedin
group where i keep on posting and where
we keep on posting about these
job opportunities that are associated
with a similar kind of training that you
are that you're getting from this sort
of uh experience
now um what we are working on in a
regular basis is some of these
cutting-edge and modern
research areas where
big data is used where biomedical
information is used where clinical
information is used where even lifestyle
information is used so integration of
all this data
and for any sort of you know
personalized care is precision medicine
so
there are a lot of projects that we have
prepared and worked with many students
that specifically discussed about a
certain problem so when it is about
precision medicine then it becomes like
really um about individuals so if you
think about in the context of an
individual just think about the think
about the amount of opportunity that
this field is going to produce because
right now it's like one drug maybe if
it's a large and large number of
population maybe like maybe one drug is
looked at and given to a
entire country
but
what we have seen and uh what we have
understood that due to these subtle
changes that we discussed and understood
and while we are learning about
transcriptomics because we are comparing
all of the
uh all of the sequencing and all of the
reads that we get for gene expression
and then we are looking at the genomics
data and then we are looking at the
epigenomics data and then the
environmental factors that we are
understanding from metagenomic data so
it's it's really
now
opening up all of those correlations
that we were not able to see and we were
just guessing so
because of that there's a huge
opportunity in population health and
there's a lot of application in
biotechnology and agriculture and
there's uh this new field called space
omix so i can keep on like talking about
this for hours and hours so this this is
not enough and there's so much is going
on so these are some of the
opportunities and also like um the
projects that you saw there are some of
the example projects that they put
together that helps anyone to understand
that how this sort of research has been
conducted because they are taken from
peer reviewed publications and as well
as they are taken from data sets that
are
available on uh geo sra all the public
repositories that are hosted on the
uh amazing uh ncbi portal
so uh about the research uh
the way we are trying to addressing a
research it's more data-driven research
so
when we are doing a hypothesis based
research
we have some sort of idea about how this
hypothesis of arts will be
like now when we are looking at this
from a very different prospect when we
are looking at the data first and
understanding that what this data can
answer so that's data driven research
and there is so much of data which is
available out there there is a lot of
opportunity for research so identifying
gaps
and finding those unanswered question
defining your uh question these are some
of the things that we are helping as a
mentor to the research community to the
participants who are joining the
research fellowship program and then
there is a
there is a
strict structure that enables us to
track to enables us to understand that
how uh idea can be you know structured
into a research project can be
structured into a you know a report can
be structured into a publication so this
all of this work goes on when one person
joins the research fellowship and go
through this entire process of
introduction evaluation practice and
then communication is one of the biggest
uh key to uh having a successful
training out of this so
all those who have been communicating
and coming to the meetings and having
this profile that actually showcases
like towards the end when you're
completing your research your project is
also highlighted in your profile and
that enables any of the employers any of
the collaborators to know more about
your research and and reach out to you
for the same
so uh it's very simple to upload this so
we have a mechanism that enables any of
the users to upload their own project
once they're completed their project and
obviously there's a tracking system that
enables us to understand that if you
have reached a level where you can start
a project or not so the the the concept
is to earn ten thousand points and ten
thousand points can be easily earned
when you start finishing the course and
you start running pipelines on tbi and
platform and that will happen when we
start the training programs and before
that we are our objective is for you to
go through the basic coursework that is
available for free and then we will be
able to you know quickly
go through these different topics that
we are talking about exciting topics
that we are talking talking about and
you to make the most out of this
training out of this opportunity so some
of the examples that we've been working
and some of these students have been
able to publish able to complete these
projects that involves you know working
on different of these research areas
including space omics
[Music]
and its application and seeing how
it affects astronaut astronauts health
and what are the different ways we can
improve and then there are uh like very
uh specific research which is uh which
is related to precision medicine
precision oncology and
very mechanistic related research so
there is a lot of research ideas that we
can work with uh and working with
already and there are already available
projects for those who do not have a
research idea but would want to work on
a research uh research problem that that
sort of opportunity is also there
because of these collaborative projects
so from you know different levels so we
have high school students who are really
inquisite are into this have able to
finish then we have post doctoral
fellows who are using this for some
clinical study and then we have phd
students and undergraduate and masters
students as well
completing and finishing these
coursework and the research project in a
very short period of time
so uh i mean some of the recognition
that people have get obviously
not just to go for a better university
and better degree and all of that but
also to win uh prestigious prizes uh
science fairs and uh also
to be able to show this in our
omics research symposium that we do
every two years and where we discuss
meet with all the experts in the
industry discuss about the research
recent advancements and give an
opportunity to our research fellows a
platform for research fellows to
showcase their research and get win
prices so that's all about the research
part and how we are doing this research
fellowship program and along with other
training programs which would make sense
because once you know about some of the
specific training you can easily apply
this to a research project which is also
an option and this is like mostly
available throughout the year but this
is like a unique opportunity to work
with us uh within this uh scope of this
program and also because uh it's
available at uh we are also providing a
50 scholarships
for those who are interested so a great
opportunity for the summer for all of
you and i hope that many of you would
join and start working with us in these
specific areas of research utilizing
public repositories and public data and
our own guidance and the platform and
the community
so that is all that i wanted to add to
this presentation and we are very sorry
if we have extended this time and we've
been talking for a very long time so uh
unlike um i would now like to pass this
stage to sonalika to help you all of or
help all of you with the with the
registration process and understand that
how you can start with the
utilizing the resources that we just
discussed thank you
thank you so much dr mohamed for
explaining about the research fellowship
program
now i would like to take you all through
the registration process for all of
these programs that dr raghav
uh explained and also dr moment so
before i get on to the registration part
i'll quickly go through the portal
and help you all how to navigate and
pick the resources that you are
interested to go through so first of all
uh jabs in the beginning had mentioned
that you all must have an account on the
omixlogic learn portal so for those who
have not yet created their account and
join midway or late
the link is in the chat box please refer
to this link and have an account for
yourself so that you have the access to
all of these wonderful resources that we
discussed about today
and now moving forward i'll just quickly
go through the profile section
it's very important to have a complete
profile as dr mohit mentioned uh that we
have various opportunities for those who
complete the training uh the only
project training successfully that's why
it's very important for you to have a
complete profile which includes a
profile picture your name should be in
title case and you should add a brief
bio about yourself that would be about
your educational research background
your research interests this really
helps the mentors know about your
progress your interests your field and
also help the recruiters pick the best
profile
and
with this i just go to the courses tab
now and explain how you can pick the
resources that we uh discussed about
today
on this portal you have these styles on
the right side so if you're interested
to look at the various courses that on
project provides just click on the
courses tab and you will get a list of
courses which includes a course on
transcriptomics genomics metagenomics
epigenomics data science machine
learning
and you can pick any of these courses
and then you have various example
projects as well that we discussed about
from which you can learn about the
application of these various different
omics data types and understand how you
can answer a research question in hand
i think i need to
all right now with this i'll just
quickly jump into the registration
process steps
i think i need to reload it yeah
okay so i'll take up the very first
program that is biomedical data analysis
and art and python
now uh these programs which we are
discussing for uh discussing about today
uh is uh specifically for lprn and maybe
that's what all of you think but yes
these programs can also be taken up by
people who are not from nbrn and
nepi institutions and that is why we
have this orientation session for all of
you who are interested to join these
programs and i'll just quickly go
through these registration pages and
tell you how you can become a part of
these programs so this is the very first
program that i want to discuss about
that is biomedical data analysis and r
and python
i just quickly put the link in the chat
box to this program page
all right so once you are on this page
you will find all the details that are
important for this program first of all
when the program begins it's 15th of
june and it's a three months program
that would end on 15th of september but
you can join in asynchronously for a one
month duration as well and on this
program page you will find the
information about the programs schedule
that is what all sessions are we going
to have on which all dates are we going
to have these sessions what are the
topics that will be covered and what are
the associated resources that you need
to go through and complete as a part of
a particular session
and how is this program page helpful yes
it does give you the information about
each and every session but it will also
help you go through the session
recordings so for each and every session
that is listed here we are going to have
uh session recordings mentor recorded
sessions and i'll be uploading these
recordings on the program page on the
date of the program which you can go
through and also you are supposed to
first go through the session recording
second go through these associated
resources all these coding lessons that
are a part of this program page now when
you go through these uh session
recordings and also uh practice these
coding lessons you will definitely
encounter some questions or you would
like to talk to the mentor out of
curiosity so we have uh groups on skype
and also slack channels which you can
join and anytime clarify your question
uh from the mentor and also we'll be
having some live sessions in between uh
these asynchronous sessions where you
can meet the mentor and take your
questions
now how do you register for this program
so if you scroll down you're going to
find three different levels for this
program
uh
gizelle i'll just get back to your
question uh i'll just explain the steps
to register first and then i'll get back
to your question
all right so we have uh three different
subscription levels the first is
beginner then we have an intermediate
level and then we have an advanced level
so uh
for all of these different levels the
resources are going to be the same yes
the resources which includes the access
to comics logic resources which are the
coursework the session recordings
associated resources everything is going
to remain the same the difference lies
in the time duration for which you are a
part of the program and also the access
to mental guidance now in the business
level you will be uh able to have such
sessions like the ones we have today
group sessions where we have discussions
you can take your questions ask your
queries resolve them in the intermediate
session you can schedule one-on-one
meeting with the mentor and
clarify questions and in the advanced
level you will get some extra time
period to work on a research proposal
and then finally get started with the
research project as an outcome of this
training all right so that is the
difference between beginner intermediate
and advanced level uh the three
subscription levels and their
differences remains the same for all of
these programs that i'm going to uh
discuss about
uh today
and there's just a difference in the
costing of these programs so how you can
take this particular subscription just
click on the select option button and
you'll be directed to the payment
gateway and that way you can enroll for
the program
and those who are opting for
scholarships now i'll take question that
gizel has asked in the chat box
now for those who are opting for a
scholarship
you need to reach out to us at marketing
advert omixlogic.com
and we will be able
to uh help you out with your enrollment
with the scholarship
uh before you reach out to marketing
aspirate on exotic.com please make sure
that you fill out the scholarship form
so i'll quickly give the scholarship
form as well in the
chat
yes this is the scholarship form please
fill out the form first and then reach
out to marketing added honors logic.com
for the specific program that you are
entrusted uh to enroll in with a
scholarship and we help you uh get
started with your training
after uh the biomedical data analysis
program let's talk about introduction to
bioinformatics training program
now again this particular pro program
page will help you look at various
details that is when this program begins
what is the schedule of this program uh
all the session details have been
mentioned here
that includes the topics the associated
resources and also you will have the
recordings on the dates of each and
every session and these resources are
actually lessons of various courses on
the portal itself and also each and
every session will be supplemented with
some extra
extra material and also additional
videos by our guest speakers and
sessions that you'll be getting over an
email and to enroll for this particular
program the process is the same scroll
down i'll just give the link in the chat
once again
uh scroll on this page and you will find
these three different subscription
levels that i explain
and uh you uh you can pick the one that
uh works the best for you
so this is about introduction to
bioinformatics program
anyone if anyone has any question please
put them in the chat box and i can pick
it up
all right so the third program that we
wanted to discuss was about infectious
diseases
and the link to this particular program
is in the chat so to in
to enroll yourself for the infectious
diseases program you need to visit the
program page and the dates have been
mentioned and please don't bother
yourself by uh
look by
looking at this detail for lb iron and
ap students i've as i've mentioned
earlier also the non rn and mp students
researchers are difficult to get
involved in these programs uh the
differences lies in the registration
steps and that's what we have been uh
have been discussing till now all right
so for infectious diseases uh we have
the syllabus mentioned here again i'm
not going through each and every session
here for each and every program that we
are going through because it will uh be
too lengthy so you have the link you can
go through these session details
yourself and if you have any question
please feel free to reach out to us and
we'll uh clarify the same for you
all right and to register for this
particular program you can
pick up the subscription level that
works best for you and you have the
scholarship form if you would like to
fill it out and get scholarship for the
program you
you can do the same and you have the
email address as well
and also i would like to mention here
that on each and every program page you
will find a program course and project
library now what is this as a part of
this program you will also get the
access to these various resources which
includes uh for example if you talk
about infectious
infectious
diseases program then along with this
program you're going to get an access to
these courses and example projects that
i mentioned here and also you are
supposed to go through these resources
as a product as a part of the project
so that was about infectious diseases
and
now let's go to our next program which
is transcriptomics for chronic diseases
till the page loads let me look at the
thank you so much dr raghav
uh for putting the link in the chat
all right so for this particular program
you again have the dates mentioned now i
would like to specifically answer one
question that i usually get from the
participants they sometimes ask me that
if they're not let's say available from
15 june and they're visited let's say
first week of our first week of july or
august and they would like to enroll
them so can they so the answer is yes
you can enroll any time between 15 june
to 30th september it definitely has to
be a one month training program for you
then that you can follow asynchronously
so you can enroll in these programs um
according to your own schedule and
because we have these resources um
uh asynchronous that is you can go
through these session recordings at your
own pace and
that is why you can uh take up the
resources the program even if you have a
busy schedule you can go go through
these resources at its own pace so you
can definitely enjoy and get started
with your training process
and again we have the sessions are
scheduled the
resources mentioned and also the topics
mentioned for each and every session for
this particular program
and then we have the
subscription levels mentioned here for
the program which you can pick
which work best for you so the link is
in the chat box and you can uh enroll in
the program
now last but not the least let's discuss
about the research fellowship program
so after training program project
sessions will start or is it
simultaneous uh but if you want to get
enrolled in the research fellowship
program let's all get started with your
research project after a training
program then the first thing that i
would suggest to you is that an advanced
level works the best for you where you
can actually work with the mentor on
designing your research proposal and
then get started with your research
project right so uh the project sessions
as in you're saying it really a varies
from from subscription to subscription
level for each and every participant and
if you're interested to take it up then
yes
it will start after the training program
not simultaneous because it's important
for you to actually learn about the
concepts run the pipelines and see how
everything uh
has to be like how your data has to be
processed how you run the pipelines how
you get the outputs how you interpret
your outputs right so you need to get a
training first and only then you can
work on a research project and if you
are already trained with the specific
type of data analysis that you would
like to work on in your research project
then yes you can work simultaneously or
simply start with the research
fellowship program where you work on
your research project
yes exactly but when you talk about the
training program this and i'm talking
about trust the training program and if
you want to be a part of the research
fellowship program so it will be like a
training program first and then three
months or six months of the research
fellowship program it would be that ways
i hope i was able to answer your
question and if you have if you still
have any uh question or confusion you
can definitely unload yourself also and
take up your question
all right i think i was able to answer
your question
uh next we have a question by mukesh
uh dr raghav can you take the first part
of mukev's question where he's asking
about is biomedical data analysis aren't
beneficial who have to work on ml data
science or only for researcher i'll take
up the payment question uh from
i think you're the best person to answer
this question that's why i am referring
it to you okay biomedical data analysis
are in python beneficial for
beneficial who have to
work on machine learning data science or
only for researchers
now what is the contrast here
i think i mean yeah if you want to work
on
if you want to work if you want to
understand how machine learning and
various algorithms of machine learning
is employed for big data bioinformatics
analysis then you should use biomedical
data analysis r in python i mean
specifically we have named it in such a
way that the focus is on data analysis
part is on data science part not on the
biology part i mean the biology part
comes
after you have completed the analysis
and after you have gotten the results
and how do you relate and how do you
interpret the results
with the phenotypical changes or with
the disease biology or with the systems
uh systems annotation and etc so more
and more focus is going to be about
applying different and various uh
methods yeah of playing various bio
ml method machine learning methods that
is suited for different data and
different question so it is also
uh suitable for researcher who wants to
get an introduction or who wants to
understand how machine learning methods
are employed for bioinformatics data
analysis
using big data and if
we also had students who who were
well-versed in machine learning data
analysis only to uh yeah and i've not
worked with the biobiological data so
the focus is going to be using bio
biological data or big data with
genomics data
what all you can learn and what are the
challenges and how to overcome them
for employing different machine learning
algorithms or big or big data so that is
going to be the focus and forefront of
this and
so i think i partly answered your
query if you want to learn
all the nuts and bolts of understanding
or of nuts and bolts of using machine
learning data then you have to take
biomedical data analysis
of course
dr raghav and thank you sparsh for
answering uh path's question i think
first you should reach out to park maybe
and uh uh par sparsha is the best person
who can help you uh enroll in the
program and get started and answer all
your questions and uh making to answer
your last part where you were actually
asking about the payment method in inr
or others so uh
i would like to specify here that you
can definitely proceed with uh the
payments uh on the portal and by picking
it by choosing the select option button
but if anyhow you face any issues and
yes we do have alternate payment payment
options as well uh yes in inr uh you can
use various uh different platforms to
proceed with the same and uh to do so uh
spurs is the best person she'll help you
out with it mukesh please share your
email address so that we can send you
out all these details in more detail and
also part it would be great if you could
share your email address as well so that
we can reach out to you with each and
every detail
[Music]
uh
bang with a beginner subscription it's
not possible for you to uh make a
project in the end because you'll just
have an access for a month's duration
where you will be able to just complete
the
training part all right so if you pick
up the beginner subscription level let's
say you can complete your training first
and then get started with your research
project by enrolling yourself with the
research fellowship program that that
would be the best case for you
and if you pick up the advanced
subscription then yes you can work
on your research proposal
by actually because you will get some
extra days that would be around 15 to 20
days where you can actually work on your
research proposal and get started with
your research work so yes that's
possible with an advanced subscription
plan
thank you so much
for sharing the information
has shared the contact number for indian
citizens who can reach out to us by
calling out on this number
and if you are not in india and you want
to connect with us
you can maybe use whatsapp and reach out
to us anyways email is the best option
and that we have shared in the chat
marketing address on logic.com
and please make sure that you have this
uh email address added to your address
book so none of the emails lands in
promotions points
okay so now i would uh finally like to
discuss about the research fellowship
program that we have been talking about
and it really seems that a lot of you
are uh interested to work on a research
project
so uh how do you get to the research
project page here in the menu bar you
can see this research uh option here if
you click on the research option you'll
be redirected to the research fellowship
page where you can enroll yourself for
three months or six months
now if you uh go to this research
fellowship page and click on the get
started button here you will find two
options as we have discussed earlier
three months and six months you have two
levels here bigger and advanced now in
the beginner level you will get the
access to educational cloud pipelines
and advanced uh level you will get that
access to the research from pipelines
where you can take an access to an ftp
account as well if you have data you did
not even lag so that like that is the
main difference between the beginner and
the advanced a subscription level you
can pick the level uh which
suits you the best and proceed further
now again if you want to enroll in the
research fellowship program as dr mohit
mentioned that we have been
providing some scholarships to uh
interested participants you can reach
out to us on our email address and also
fill out the scholarship form and we
will our team will
review your application and get back to
you with your scholarship and then you
can get started
and if you want to enter for the six
months you simply click on this uh
button here and you'll get the options
for six months
so that was it about all the
registration steps for various programs
that we discussed and also the research
fellowship program
and now i would like to mention here one
more thing
today we discussed the registration
steps for students researchers and
faculties who are not from ldrn or maybe
now if you are from lbrn and nippy and
you want to enroll in the program
for nappy you need to simply email us at
marketinglogic.com with the program that
you're interested to enroll in and also
you need to make sure that that you have
signed up on the portal and you have an
affiliate profile please let us know
when you have uh cover these steps and
uh email us and we'll get you started
with your training under nippy
and if you are from lbrn you need to
register on red cap if you are from lbrn
i i'll repeat you need to register on
red cap and we'll get your registration
via red cap and get you started with the
training program
[Music]
yes gizelle the uh
course the training program that we
discussed and the research project are
two separate phases not one but there
are two separate phases in the training
program our focus is just to get you
trained and get a good hands-on with our
example projects to get you up to work
on your own research uh question and
to get started with your research work
you then need to get a become
you need to enroll for the research
fellowship program
yes
that would have
another
batch of fees that
you need to proceed with and again
scholarship is applicable on both of
these on the training programs and also
research the research fellowship program
so you have it covered
[Music]